i'd like to call this meeting of the
public works and highways committee to
order and to start just a couple of
things
we have four bills
we're going to hear all four of them
today
four senate bills
my intention is if at all possible to
execute those bills today so we don't
have to come back in on a different day
to do that
but if we can't reach agreement we will
come in
on a different day
just a heads up
but that also means that if you make the
motion you have to write the committee
report and you're not leaving today till
i have the committee report please um
two of the bills have to be into the
calendar next week
um no matter what we do with it there
are early bills and we'll get to them
they deal with appropriations of of
money
um
so that's kind of where we are as a
committee
there are two bills that are being
sent to other
committees
that deal with highway funding
senate bill 401
deals with
30 million dollars for apportionment out
to the cities and towns
apportionment a in the rsa
and 36 million to
municipal bridge aid which would be
non-lapsing money and that's all coming
out of um
monies otherwise not appropriated in the
budget
and the other one is
um
house bill
1221 is being amended by the senate and
this is the so-called
gas tax holiday
it will probably
go to
ways and means
for concurrence or
or request a committee a conference
i bring that up because both of those
deal with the highway fund of which we
are
uh the guardians in large part so
having said that we'll move into the
four bills
the first bill
is senate bill 201
relative to naming a bridge in the town
of romney and a bridge in the town of
center harbor
um
i'd like to i understand uh senator
gaida the the um
prime sponsor is not available but mr
fredetn is available to speak
and for
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee my name is daley fernett i i'm
the legislative aide to senator bob
gaida and i'm here to introduce senate
bill 201
so this bill names a bridge in the town
of romney as the joseph garrity memorial
bridge and a bridge in the town of
so joseph garrity was a state trooper
unfortunately he died in the line of
duty a few years ago
so we would like to give him the honor
of naming this bridge after him he was a
he was a good man he did a lot for this
the other gentleman mr reilly
he was a very dedicated citizen of
center harbor
and uh he gave a lot to that town he
worked on some historical sites
especially the 1843 townhouse
so to honor him we would like to in his
service to that town we would like to
ask for your support on this bill
i would defer any uh questions to any
he asked not to to take questions
it
we'll wait uh we'll hit up the next
speaker
uh next
pink card i have is from representative
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is ned
gordon i represent grafton county
district nine
and i can speak to the first part of
this bill and particularly with regard
to the part which references joseph
garrity
joseph garrity was a state trooper
he along with another state trooper were
transporting a prisoner
uh up to
the
jail in haverhill
and they were passing through the town
of warren
and the town of warren
there is a bridge with a relatively
sharp curve
and as they were going around the curve
a a truck carrying lumber from canada
was coming down in the other direction
its load shifted and the lumber fell off
the truck and on to their cruiser
it killed both police officers both
state troopers and the prisoner
today if you drive up through the town
of warren on route 25
you will three see three crosses
next to the road which have been placed
there
and
uh as a memorial to the three people who
were killed
the other state trooper who was with
trooper garrity at the time
has been recognized by the state and a
piece of road in a community where he
lived was named after that state trooper
no recogni recognition of trooper
garrity other than that cross beside the
road on route 25.
we
felt that he
lived he was a respected trooper state
trooper
not
uh
not in that position for all that long
but
he was very well regarded and well
regarded in his community which was the
community of romney where he lived
and so
appropriately
with senator gaiada we have asked that a
bridge and this is a bridge on main
street in rumney uh on a state road
which crosses the baker river be named
that
sign be placed there
and that's
the purpose of the bill and we would ask
you to consider that i can't speak to
the second half of the bill i don't know
about
thank you
questions i do
who's
representative
is this the buffalo road bridge
this is the main street no this is the
main street bridge as i understand it
and the main street is you go from route
25 and you go into
rumney right on the roadway that
eventually goes up to stinson lake but
you cross over the baker river there's a
bridge there that crosses over the river
oh okay
all right thank you
representative
abbott
yes thank you mr chairman i just
wondered
if the town of romney
has approved
i do not know whether the town of romney
the naming uh i
can't tell you whether
senator guy to ask i don't know for sure
the reason being that when we do any of
these naming bills is there a question
here or a statement would you believe
that
that the uh
we usually get the the municipality to
prove that
i i think that makes good sense but um i
can tell you that i don't believe that
the town of romney certainly would have
any further questions from members of
seeing none thank you very much
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
i have a pink card from mr lambert of
from the d.o.t
he's here to answer any questions
anybody might have about
naming these
two bridges anybody have questions of
yep if if you would come forward
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for listening to
the testimony i don't have much
testimony i can tell you that
i worked with the previous legislative
aide for representative guida griffin
roberts when he was putting this bill
together initially they wanted to name
route 25
that highway is already named the moosa
lock highway
so they worked
with the community so they did reach out
to the town of romney
to see if they'd have any issues with
the i wasn't part of that discussion but
my understanding is that when they
realized that route 25 was already named
they looked at the main street bridge as
a secondary location in the town of
romney and they did work with the town
to get their endorsement i don't think
that's in writing but they did reach out
to them
thank you
any further questions of the department
see none thank you
is there anybody
who has
not testified
um
on senate bill 201
wishes to speak now is there anybody who
testified once who wishes to speak again
seeing none
the public hearing on senate bill 201
is closed i will now open the executive
session on senate bill 201
did i scare everybody by saying you had
to write the committee report today
move approval mr chairman
thank you uh representative boyd moves
approval second
it's seconded by
representative
thomas
um
seeing none mr chairman i'm sorry i
about question about the the center
harbor part david riley is anything like
any proof that the town of center harbor
supported naming that bridge for david
reilly
sponsors are here i can't answer that
question and it did not come up looking
through
what was
the committee report from
the senate
that question was never asked there
either
any further discussion
oh
representative faulkner i just want to
say i think the lack of
letters from the town is something that
would certainly concern us more if this
were originating
in this committee i want to
i think we can offer
some uh
some credibility to our senate
colleagues for having reviewed this
before and i'm willing to
to accept
that
i i tend to agree with that coming from
a second committee the town is towns
have had an opportunity to weigh in
through their representatives if nothing
else
any other comments or questions or
concerns
thank you mr chair
representative acton yes
representative sumero yes
representative phil dolphy yes
representative newton yes
representative blazik
representative bordes is here
representative kaczynski
is here
yeah i didn't see
representative close yes
representative thompson yes
representative boyd boyd votes high
representative clutier uh yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebel aye
representative jack yes
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner yes
representative eaton yes
query
yes
representative bunker yes
chairman graham
yes
mr chair the vote is 22-0 ought to pass
the vote being twenty two
zero on ought to pass
is there any objection to the consent
calendar
see none
and once again
we have a break um
i thought a couple more of the
sponsors would be here but
not being that the executive session on
senate bill 201 is closed and at 10 30
we will hear
uh senate bill 278 thank you very much
go get a cup of coffee but don't go too
far
all right if everybody would try to take
their
seats again
we're about to open the hearing on
senate bill 278
i will call the committee order
and
open the hearing on senate bill 278 fn
relative to funding for the piscataqua
river turning basin project in the port
authority project
and none of the sponsors are here and i
but i will recognize uh representative
evil
okay um good morning mr chair and
members of the committee senator rebecca
perkins cuoco wasn't able to be here
today and asked me to introduce the bill
on her behalf
for the record my name is
representative karen ebel i represent
merrimack district five which is new
london and newbury which is quite some
so
sb 278 is a request from gino marconi
port director of the new hampshire port
authority in the 2019 budget package a
sum of money was assigned to a port
authority project in rye harbor
those funds were refunded by the
contractor and sb 278 will allow those
funds to be made available to the
piscataqua river turning basin widening
project
the piscataqua river turning basin has
been an issue for years with the size of
the turning basin no longer being
sufficient for modern vessels
widening the turning basin with these
additional funds will be a massive boon
to the seacoast economically
making the area more efficient and much
safer
in the 2021 budget package 1.5 million
dollars was appropriated to the turning
basin project
sb 278 is taking the remaining
two hundred thousand fifty one dollars
and one hundred and
one hundred and forty three dollars from
the 2019 rye harbor project and adding
to the total for the turning basin
project
although the language of the beer bill
beer
although the language of the bill is not
clear in this respect at first glance
this bill is not drawing new funds
instead it's reallocating funds from the
2019 budget cycle that were reabsorbed
by the general fund because no
non-lapsing language was used at the
time
the senate finance committee amended to
sb 278 to be more correct in its form
and make it more in line with other
appropriations bills
sb 278 fn passed the senate finance
committee 6-0
and this passed in the full senate on a
voice vote
mr chair as you could i was reading the
senator's statement
i'm not really able to answer any
questions but mr marconi is here and i
i'm sure he can
answer your questions
thank you for introducing the bill
see no
pertinent questions to representative
evil
um
i would call upon gina marconi
of uh p's development authority to speak
about
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
this has been a long time project the
widening of the turning basin was a
project that was identified in a
navigation safety improvement study that
was published by the army corps of
i was appointed the court director in
july of
and that's how long i've been working on
the project
this this was one of five projects in
the piscataqua river to improve
navigation safety for the large ships
that cargo ships to come in and out of
the harbor
but in the big picture this is the last
choke point in the northeast shipping
corridor you'll remember a number of
years ago they replaced the south
portland bridge
most recently they replaced the chelsea
creek bridge going into logan airport
there's been some some dredging projects
one of the other ones that they
identified in the study was
the sarah mildred long bridge and the
navigation hazards that that caused
the bridge has been replaced and this is
the last of the choke points
in the corridor
why this is so important is when the
turning basin was constructed
in 1977
it was an 800-foot turning basin because
that was the size of the ships that were
frequenting the harbor they were you
know
550-foot ships today our pilots are
turning 765 foot ships in a 800 foot
turning basin
this project expands the turning basin
to 1200 feet and actually elongates it a
little bit so as the ship comes off the
dock and gets a little set
it gives them a little more room to
swing the bow around without grounding
we've got exceptional pilots
but because of the limitations of the
turning basin
there are limitations on the movement of
cargo
daylight only
high tide only if there are wind
conditions or visibility conditions
they don't move the ship and every day
that the ship either waits outside to
come in or sits at the dock to leave
you know demerge rates on a ship that
are sitting idle can be
85 to 90 thousand dollars a day
and
those fees are passed under the
consumers because a lot of the product
that's brought in
is home heating oil kerosene diesel fuel
and propane
so as we speak
uh monday morning
the project the project
got underway this season
and the uh
the dredge season is uh
november uh to the first of april the
project permit did get an extra 15 days
but at the monday morning briefing the
corps of engineers and the contractors
indicated that there was about 42 000
cubic yards remaining
the project called for the removal of
000 cubic yards of dredge material
um of that 42 000 20 of that is
uh over dredge
so that really is only about 22 000 guys
that need to be removed and so the
scours that remove the the dredge
material to go offshore
they're 5 000 yard scouts so
they're indicating that
probably by friday they'll be finished
digging
the corps will go in monday and do their
final survey of it if there's any
cleanup that needs to be done of any
high spots they've got a week to do that
and then
i won't be back here again
asking about
turning basins
um so if i may mr chairman so what what
happened with this was is when when they
went out to bid
um
obviously construction costs have gone
up so the bid came in
higher than what was anticipated
and
so we had gotten this refund from the
when we completed rye and we paid the
army corps of engineers up front all of
the money that they asked for
we thought the project had been closed
out so when it came around to ask for
lapse extensions we didn't think we
needed one
well what happened when they finally did
the final
accounting for the rye harbor project
there was less material removed by the
contractor than was anticipated and the
contract is based on a per cubic yard
cost so that's why we got this money
back from the core
but we needed it because of the cost
um thank you
uh questions of mr marconi
representative boyd
thank you mr chairman through you to uh
mr marconi
where is the turning basin located i i
actually don't know where it is okay
i apologize i probably should have
brought a graphic with me uh the
piscataqua the the deepwater channel
starts at the entrance of the portsmouth
harbor and piscataqua river down
off of newcastle
and the deep water channel ends
just before you make that turn to go
under the
dover point bridge
so
when you look over there the last
terminal which is sprague you see these
two concrete
silos
that's the that's the end of the deep
water
and so it's on opposite side of the
channel
further questions
once the dredging is done where does all
the dredge material go to
that's a great question one of the
advantages of having this project take
so long to really get off the feet is
that
the core has has over the last five or
six years came up with a program for the
beneficial use of dredge spoils
the word spoils kind of makes everybody
go
the geotechnical borings and surveys
that were done on this material is that
it was about 80 percent hard packed
glacial sand
and so
the original
base plan was to go to a epa approved
dump site outside the isles of shoals
however in the last few years with the
beneficial use program
about 150 or 60 000 cubic yards went
down to salisbury beach and a similar
amount of the dredge material went down
to plum island and we all know the last
few years the
winter storms have decimated those
beaches so it's a beneficial use so it
went down the air it was it was dumped
you know a few hundred yards off the
beach
and the engineers and the scientists say
that the wave action will push it back
up and hopefully
restore some of the beach fronts
thank you yes sir
i have a couple um
when we talk about the budget and lapses
and everything
under this scenario we're talking about
the capital budget from 2019 for rye
harbor
that came in under and you got a refund
did we borrow all of that money i think
it was 600 and
um
37 000
or or something like that did we
actually go out and bond that entire
amount
at that time before the
uh mr chairman i don't ask i don't know
the answer to that question i'd have to
ask um i asked to have steve mclaughlin
over at admin services he's our business
agent
okay but
the
quarter of a million dollars that was
refunded from that
is enough to make up the difference
on the turning basin
you
you just said you weren't going to be
coming back
correct
some of the some of the there's some
more money that that's due
some of it is coming out of the hybrid
dredge p maintenance fund
um
excuse me
where did the other money come from
there was just this money have a drudge
p maintenance fund
and
i'm just trying to make sure that you
have enough to complete this since we
only have a week and a half or so to get
it done
if i may mr chairman this is suzy
anzaloni she's our finance director over
at pease and she's our new finance
director so i'm putting her into the
hutsey
she came up today
understand how we do things um
i believe this is all covered yes
and if it's not what what do we do after
it's going to be some time before the
corps of engineers closes out the
project
so
there is still funds that are part of
the appropriation the original
appropriation back in 2014 and 2016
that
one was for construction and one was for
the post
operation and maintenance contribution
that the corps requires
so there is still some other monies but
we don't want to touch the o m money
because
they're going to do a calculation on
that
okay thank you
any
representative tom
um
thank you mr chairman
is there any chance that you're going to
uh um
in the amount of cubic yards on this
project like you did on
on rye harbor when they do the audit
it's possible because the discussions we
had on monday morning were as i said
there there was 42 000 cubic yards that
included um 20 000 that were over
dredged
the project calls to go to 37 feet the
over dredge goes to 39 they're only
required under the contract to go to the
but the contract if they dig more than
37 feet they get paid for it
so
if they dig
37.2 feet that's what they get paid for
and and the rest of the money for the
overdredge won't get paid to him and
that was in that was in the payment that
we made to the corps of engineers so
there is a possibility
that the adage will come up short and
we'll get a refund
and i'll be returning it back to the
state
thank you very much thank you any
further questions
hi
the the information that you gave
representative peterson on the dredging
material and where it goes i'm just
wondering is that donated or sold or
what
if
the base plan is to go from the
construction site to the offshore
disposal site
if the transportation to an alternate
beneficially used site is greater or
costs more than it would be to go to the
base plan than the recipient
being the state of massachusetts would
have to pay the difference it's not it
doesn't cost us any more
it's paid by the recipient if it if it's
thank you
see no further questions
i i would just
if we were to pass this and the house
agrees with us
on the 21st which is when it would be
heard by the house it will be going to
finance committee they may have more
detailed questions on where every dollar
came from or where it's going i just
just a heads up on that one
but see no further questions
um
thank you for your testimony thank you
mr chairman members of the committee i
appreciate your time and the opportunity
having no further pink cards is there
anybody who is testified once on this
bill rest uh
desires to speak again
anybody who has not spoken who wishes to
speak saying none i will close the
public hearing
what is the will of the committee on
well somebody's going to write it
out to pass on senate bill 278
seconded by representative boyd i
the motion has been made out to pass on
to seven eight
um is there any discussion from members
of the committee
on
this
bill
saying none
the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
the clerk votes yes
representative acton yes
representative samara
yes representative phadolfy
representative newton yes
representative boris
representative kaczynski
representative close yes
representative thompson yes
representative boyd boyd vote side
representative clutier uh yes
representative edgar all right
representative ebel yes
representative jack yes
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes representative
eaton yes representative peterson yes
representative querrey
yes
representative bunker yes
chairman graham
yes
mr chair of the vote is 21-0 yay on
thank you
um
it will be on the regular calendar since
it does appropriate money
um
with that
the
executive session on senate bill 278 is
closed
our next hearing is at 11 a.m i'm
i think we have 18-0
for those uh who are going to be
testifying on senate bill 378 if you
could fill out a pink card it would be
the time being 11 a.m i will call the
public hearing
on senate bill 378-fn
and act relative to the disposal of
highway or turnpike-funded real estate
to order
and
call upon the prime sponsor senator
perkins cuoca
uh to introduce the bill
hopefully i got the name right
i was just gonna compliment you chairman
you did get the name right
thank representative evil
i i would like to thank representative
evil as well um for being here for my
last bill i had four bills to introduce
this morning so um i'm grateful to be
here with you guys and for your time
uh good morning for the record i'm
senator rebecca perkins quoca
representing district 21 city of
portsmouth and the towns of madbury lee
durham newington new market and
newfields
i'm the prime sponsor of sb 378
and act relative to the disposal of
highway or turnbike-funded real estate
this request arose because
there's a parcel in newington that
some citizens would like to preserve
through the newington historical society
and so
um it brought
up the fact that
new hampshire d.o.t only has the
authority and power to dispose of funds
of property to municipalities and in
this particular case
there's
no interest on the part of the town of
newington
to take ownership of that parcel however
you know it remains in the public
interest to have it preserved and so
we worked with senator waters and i
worked with the department of
transportation to come up with language
which would allow
new hampshire d.o.t to transfer certain
properties at less than market value to
a third party
um
in order to help provide latitude to new
hampshire d.o.t to facilitate this kind
of transfer um and other
sites for preservation and stewardship
and potentially others where there's
environmental benefit
the transfer of property in this case is
carefully worded
for a reason we wanted to
make sure that
an organization that were to take over
property for less than fair market value
from the state would be obligated to
maintain its historical or preservation
character going forward
so language requiring covenants to be in
the
deed of transfer are included in this
bill
i know that
new hampshire dot is also here to
testify
and talk about how we came up with the
language but it was in fact from the
agency um the language that's in the
bill so
uh
i will leave it at that i i hope it's a
fairly straightforward matter but i'm
more than happy to answer any questions
thank you senator uh questions
representative thompson
uh good morning
senator thank you for
presenting the bill um
there's a
in
section two roman numeral two it says if
the town city or county decides to
resell the property
do i assume that means that these
properties can only be sold at a lesser
value
to a town city or the county and not to
a private
preservation group that's right as the
statute stands now it can only be
transferred to a political subdivision
um and so that's the purpose of the
statute is to
allow the agency more latitude to
transfer to a private third party okay
thank you very much thank you mr
chairman
uh representative boyd
thank you mr chairman
senator cuoco thank you very much i
appreciate it what's
should this should all this come to
fruition and the governor signing into
law what's the what's the vision for the
property that the the community has in
mind
sure um
in this particular
parcel in newington um is a historical
railroad depot so it's
it's a building that needs to be
restored it's the newington historical
society that
wants to take stewardship over it and
has been doing fundraising which is
challenging without the ability to
obtain the property directly so
um
they you know
it is
essentially an attraction for the town
that they have it's it's near the water
and um the hope is that this group can
provide it with an endowment basically
to keep it going forward
question
um thank you mr chair and thank you
senator um would you believe that i i
would i lived in newington for many
years and i was on the budget committee
there and the
the town of newington is
really skilled at preserving their
buildings and so forth
they have a a beautiful old church that
they restored and they've done a variety
of things so um i i would have high
confidence
in them being able to pull this off as
well
we're talking about one piece of
property but this would
talk about
lots of different pieces and and we'll
listen to the department later but
can you give me any kind of definition
on what overall public interest based on
social environmental or economic
benefits actually means
[Laughter]
thank you chairman
again this language was
designed to give the agency
discretion i understand that it's a
broad definition um with the reminder
that all land disposal that happens at
the state level obviously has a very
extensive process which i'm sure the
chairman is intimately familiar with um
so i think the purpose here is to make
sure that if we're going to transfer um
to a third party at less than fair
market value that we're doing it for
some sort of public benefit and so that
was
the intent of this language i would be
open to discussing
different words if that would be
something the chairman was interested in
thank you
further questions
while the department does not take a
position on the bill
um
mr labonte from new hampshire d.o.t
um is here to
talk a little bit and to answer any
questions
thank you mr chairman as you just
mentioned i'm steve labonte i'm the
administrator of the bureau of right of
way at the new hampshire department of
transportation uh we played a little bit
of a role in in
developing this language
and as you mentioned uh earlier
this is just more than newington as far
as we see so we end up with a lot of
mitigation sites as part of projects
that if we're you know if we're altering
a road or building a road that would
impact wetlands we'll be required to um
acquire other areas
as mitigation land
the problem is is that once we acquire
it
it's held in you know
held in perpetuity
but
we're not exactly the best stewards of
it because we just don't have the
resources so for instance we there was
one up in conway that over last summer i
went up to visit i pulled into the
parking lot there's a
pile of tires there and it's not
uncommon to find old tvs and
things of that nature so the idea here
is if we can find a third party that we
convey the property to
keep in mind that property is burdened
with conservation easements or
historical restrictions so to to the
extent there's any value
it's it's it's minute
um and the idea is these these
uh third-party entities would be the
stewards
of the
the property
questions for the department
representative cloudy okay thank you mr
chairman mr labonte i assume this bill
in a way it's written if this we passed
this bill it would have to go through
the regular long-range capital planning
utilization committee process
your department
would have to submit it to us the the
long-range committee would have to
review it approve it and then it would
have to go to governor and council
any further representative faulkner
thank you
uh i don't know if you're familiar the
west lebanon train station but it seems
like
the story sounds familiar
and i wonder how this
kind of preservation might have happened
it might be happening now without this
particular
legislation is it possible to
to sell these properties at all under
the current current law
um it it well
it's possible but again we're
our view of it
when we were assisting with the
languages we really had in mind these
mitigation properties which we were
required to obtain as part of a project
for a specific reason
so it wouldn't be a property that's
really what we would consider surplus
because we have to use it either to
mitigate historical
impacts or
representative jack uh thank you mr
chairman uh thank you mr labonte so
following up on the chairman's concern
about line five you would be in the
purview of the long-range committee to
evaluate whether they thought that the
societal environmental whatever benefit
and and they could disapprove the
transfer if they didn't feel it was
warranted
by that
correct
not sure i want that
representative evil
thank you mr chair and good morning mr
labonte um
so in the situation that you just
described this mitigation issue what
what category would you see that falling
um
so the
just so i understand the question you're
so social environmental or economic
okay so for instance if under a social
i would i would
covenant might fall under a social
benefit
just because it's preserving a
community's history
under
you know if it's a wetlands mitigation
site i i would think
environmental
economic benefits that would be
where
we are conveying a piece of property
that may not be
mitigation
property but might be a piece of
property we're conveying to new
hampshire housing authority
for for housing
um it and i i don't know that that's
what we had in mind when we did this but
just talking here now i could see where
follow up
okay so what in your mitigation
um
example
the commissioner would find an exception
um it would be in the overall public
interest for environmental reasons to
relay say a wetland and what's a
non-proprietary governmental use
a non-proprietary governmental use
that comes out of 23 cfr
you take no ownership of that yeah
um and and i'm guessing a a
non-proprietary governmental use would
be something um
you know we're not leasing it to a
private entity for
any further questions i do have
uh representative thompson followed by
representative
uh mr bona you stated that um
you pulled into this place and there
were tires and and i know exactly what
you mean
and there are many of them in the state
would there be some sort of an agreement
in this transfer of property
that they do maintain these properties
and keep them in
good order
yes not only is there a uh an agreement
there's there's strict covenants that
the property is is conveyed with there's
also a roberta clause that if those
covenants are ever brought
ever
breached or the property is used for
something other than its intended
purpose which would be mitigation
um that it automatically reverts back to
the state okay thank you very much thank
thank you mr chairman for taking my uh
for letting me take and thank you for
taking my question
44-39-c
states upon determination that the
property is no longer needed by the
state the governor and council shall
first offer it to the government of the
town city or county
in which the property is located if the
town city or county refuses the offer
the governor and city council may sell
convey transfer or lease the real
property so what's stopping
the historical society or somebody from
buying the property now
without
amending it this stuff
4.39 c
if there's land that the
state wants to get rid of and the city
doesn't want it
can it just then go to sale
for to a historical society or somebody
yes quite often that that's what
happens is we'll get approached
um or like for instance we're going
through this this exercise up in conway
now that the conway bypass has been
dissolved
we're going through and we're selling up
we've once we once we determined that
there is a um
once we determine that we have identify
a property that is surplus
and it goes to long range
we then go to the we we then approach
the municipality telling this is the
property we've identified
this is the the value we've we've
appraised it at
if you have any interest please notify
us within 30 days we also do that with
the new hampshire housing authority um
and the same so
based on my reading of the statute
the municipality has what in essence is
a right of first refusal
then under a different statute 204 d i
believe it is um it then goes to the new
hampshire housing authority to see if
they can use it and after that we'll go
to
will either market it or in many cases
it's we've been approached by in a
butter because it's a it's a oddly
shaped
uh
inaccessible piece of property that's
only good to the abutter so that we
wouldn't bother marketing it on putting
it on the market we just go directly to
them
but we still have to offer it under this
statute we still have to offer that
piece to the municipality
eventually down the line what if it is
hypothetically a piece of property that
nobody seems to want and somebody comes
in and makes an offer that is currently
way below
what is considered
the assessed value does the state can
the state then sell it to them or do
they have to hang on to it i don't think
chairman graham would let me get away
with that when i went to long range
if he if he would then i can tell you
senator d'alessandro won't so
that's that's those checks and balances
that we have long range first views it
and then ultimately the the ultimate
one more well i might have two more
about you know i'm just i'm i'm curious
i'm trying to wrap my arms around this
and i'm happy so does this does the
state have a bunch of land that it's
can't do anything with because they
can't get current market value for it
not so much that we can't get current
market value but i will would say
throughout the state from the various
projects there these odd slivers of land
that even in the butter doesn't want
because it's so small and oddly shaped
that they're not going to pay us any
money for it
thank you mr chairman
did you have another
um
yeah is the gist of this
statue
so they're able to quickly
sell it for
fair market value is that what this is
all about in a nutshell
in a nutshell this is the
shaped
first of all the department really
doesn't necessarily have an interest in
selling properties at less than fair
market value because once we sell a
property it goes back to the fed
but
it goes into
our pool of money that we can use for
future projects so it's really not in
the department's interest it's really
these properties that
are
purchased
for
for mitigation sites
that we were required by a project
because of the impacts either due to
historical assets or to wetlands
to
purchase land and hold it in perpetuity
to to
i
i'm not sure if that's answering your
exactly
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um this property in
question in
new market do you know what the value is
of that property and what the offer is
on that
i i don't have that information in in
front of me i don't know that we've
completed an appraisal at this time but
asked another question
follow-up
so
this talk of the public benefit could
the public benefit be considered to be
getting the highest price for that
property
and returning it back to the people that
paid for it put the money up originally
i could see where that argument could be
made
thank you
um let's not get too hung up on one or
two examples of
what properties may or may not fall
under this this would be a generalized
policy from the state of new hampshire
that
groups could use
to come forward
with a proposal
to
acquire property from the state at less
than what we paid for it or less than
what it is worth
for
social
environmental economic benefits
or
for
non-proprietary governmental use
and that's really what we will be
debating in our executive session
not whether or not the
newington should be able to preserve a
building or if somebody
wants to preserve the general sullivan
bridge for example um
so um i i just cautioned the committee
on that that we can talk about those
issues in the executive session but
let's try to nail down
what the
policy will be in this bill if it was to
go forward
and become law
and
i do have one question
you briefly mentioned
that somewhere if we were to go forward
with this type of process
that within the transfer covenants
there would be
something that says if you don't live up
to this like you allow tires to be
dumped on the property we would get it
back for free or get it just
no so how a roberta clause works is it
it's probably not something like
tires it's more like okay we've granted
you this property it's burdened with
this conservation easement and all of a
sudden you've put condos up
it reverts back to the state
automatically
so we don't buy it it comes back to us
now something like we saw tires that
would probably be a letter to the
you know to the organization who's
accepted it notifying them that
there's a breach of the covenants
but the same bottom line is if that
organization has gone out of business um
and nonprofits go away all the time um
what happens at that point
so if the organization goes out of
business
the property would
i guess the state could
at that point take some type of action
like a quiet title action to gain the
property back or find another
that is all of the pink cards i have on
senate bill 378
is there anybody who has not testified
on the bill that wishes to testify at
this time is there anybody who's
testified once who wishes to speak a
second time see none
the
public hearing on senate bill 378
is closed
and i will open
general discussion on the bill at this
point before we take a motion let's just
um if you're going to talk to me you
i think the terms seem too general
you know i'd like to see this committee
have better control over property that's
sold in any shape and manner okay
there
there is a committee that um
representative clutier mentioned earlier
long-range planning and utilization
which does have to pass on
any property being sold not just from
the department of transportation but
from any
agency that whole state land but it is
small group made up of members of public
works finance from both
house and senate
representative faulkner
i think the key here is the
makes this more specific is that each
individual sale is going to be covered
by
the you know covenants in the deed and
that i've got faith in the state to be
able to
write those covenants in a manner that
protects the state's interests so
i i'd be in favor of providing this
flexibility
yeah
one of the uh
what seems like it could be problematic
was
the question that you brought up
about what if a
non-profit or an organization granted
this land
goes out of business it seems as though
in your reversion clause
that might be added into that
clause
going forward so that it would prevent
us from getting into
legal issues with trying to take the
land back or whatever
um i don't see why that
could be very easily added wouldn't need
to be in the bill but
representative ebal
um
thank you mr chair
i actually
i like the intent of this bill um
i don't understand why the state should
only be able to sell property that it
wants to sell to
municipalities i think that
really limits its opportunities and
i think if the state
is interested in selling land of the
type that mr labonte was describing they
should be able to
fair market value can be a little bit of
a fuzzy
concept because it assumes that there's
always a buyer that wants to buy at fair
market value but there may be times that
it's really really is in the public
interest for
land to be sold and um like in the
situations they described and i think we
should build in that that latitude
for them so i'm supportive i'm not sure
about every single word in what's here
the
most of the the property that is
conveyed out of any agency does not go
to a municipality or county or even the
housing finance authority it does go to
a third party
only because most towns and cities don't
want to buy more property um they want
somebody to buy it so they can charge
them taxes
by and large um
and
so it
usually they they have the first writer
refusal as mr lebronte said and that's
about it most of them don't don't do it
um but there is that
representative jack
thank you i'm trying to remember if uh
the normal long-range action has a
reversionary clause the ones that uh
come before them now so this is sort of
a new thing that's
coming up where if the nonprofit doesn't
perform properly the state will get it
back is that
and that's kind of the way i see it and
it's kind of a nebulous in my own mind a
whole nebulous comment that we probably
ought to drill down a bit more before we
put it into statute
representative clooney
okay mr chairman if it's inappropriate
this time i'd like to make a motion of
interim study and i would like to speak
to my motion
uh representative clutier moves that um
senate bill 378 be found
um be placed in interim study is there a
second second
who
from representative jack
their further discussion on the motion
of interim study on this bill
yes mr chairman i'd like to speak um
i i think i like the intent i mean i
think the sponsors have good intent but
i think as i'm listening to the
questions and the debate we're having i
think there's still two a number of
unanswered questions that i think we
need to look at this bill and there may
be some changes we need to make in the
language before we pass it and become
law
and i'm very sensitive as a long-time
member and former chair of the long
range committee
of how we do things
and i think
we've got to be very careful in doing
this
and i'm just concerned that you know we
could convey it to a non-profit
organization in the future who knows
what happens with that
non-profit organization but i i do like
the intent but i think it needs a little
bit more work and i think it could be
ready for consideration next term thank
you
for those members of the committee
what interim study means is we will be
back here in the fall
to to work on and vote on this bill at
that point there are two options that
the committee can recommend
which is
recommended for future legislation or
not recommended for future legislation
it is not just a polite way to kill a
bill
so we would um be back i would try to do
it around the same time as veto day
rather than coming down a different day
but
it does mean that we would be coming
back but it also means that we would
have the opportunity
to
actually drill down and
figure out exactly what the bill should
say to be filed for the next
term
that's just
what interim study means it has no
bearing on how you're going to vote this
time i hope
um
any further discussion
see none the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
clerk votes yes
representative acton yes
directive representative sumero no
representative phidolfi yes
representative newton yes
representative blasic
represent
senator board representative
representative kaczynski yes
can everybody hear me muttering
representative close yes
representative thompson yes
representative boyd boyd vote sign
representative clutier yes
representative edgar all right
representative ebel yes representative
jack yes
representative abbott yes
representative newman
yes
represent peterson yes
that's why i mutter
representative quarry
no
chairman graham
yeah
yes
mr chairman the vote is 18 to 3 in favor
of
interim study
thank you um for the members who voted
against the motion will there be
a minority
report
we can put it on the consent calendar
would you prefer it be on the regular
calendar for those who voted
against the
okay we'll go on the consent calendar
we'll see if it stays there
you very much and the executive session
on
uh senate bill 378 is
closed
next hearing is at one o'clock again it
deals with money
um so we have to finish it today
um
so representative clutier representative
boyd can take a couple of minutes to
write their committee reports
i know you are
i have one already okay mr chairman do
you have to pay for work or just write
it out just write it out at this point
i've got paperwork i think oh you
get with the clerk
thank you so i will see you all back
here at one o'clock uh for those of you
who can make it back i do need a quorum
thank you very much
thank you and i'm not sure if the
cafeteria is open or not
yeah
thank you for making that
well i i just i'll admit i'm a long tent
wrong i'm going to remember and
representative graham those of us have
to deal with those issues i think it's
well i mean i don't think it's wrong
it's really strange because a lot of it
goes to a butters
point
zero one
yeah time being one o'clock
i'm going to call the committee to order
and open the hearing on senate bill
346-fn
and call
the prime sponsor or senator avard
and thank you committee members it's
good to see you all
and for the record i'm senator kevin
avart
i represent district 12
and i am the prime sponsor of this bill
and
i love the ocean
i love the beach
i like walking on the ocean and i like
walking on the jetty
and when i was uh
walking my dogs with my wife a couple of
springs ago on at hampton beach
we were walking along and i'm just
looking at the jetty and i'm thinking
how many people got hurt on the jetty
how many people walk out there that are
very fit and they fall through the
cracks and they get hurt and i thought
wow
you know why don't we build a pier over
that
well uh
i saw an old lady
at the end of the at the end of the
beach near the pier so i ran over to her
and i embarrassed the heck out of my
wife
and i said uh excuse me ma'am my name is
kevin avart i'm a senator
and uh
i was just wondering i just want your
opinion what do you think about appear
over this and she said oh my gosh i've
never been on the jetty
she travels from new york
every year with her sister to hampton
beach since she was seven years old
and i said wouldn't it be nice if if
individuals that were disabled could
actually go out there where you know
instead of just the fit people the the
people that are disabled or or veterans
can get go out there and just maybe cast
the line out there and enjoy like what
like other people are doing
and she said you know i would love that
and i said oh well that's great thank
you very much for your opinion she says
oh by the way
my sister's at the the you know where
the restrooms are if you've ever been to
hampton beach there's that that pavilion
there where there's the restrooms are so
you can go to the restroom and go back
out onto the beach she's sitting in a
wheelchair right now she's just sitting
there just looking out at the ocean i
just went down here for a walk i thought
wow
great idea
so i introduced a bill and uh we had a
lot of discussion and uh turned into a
study bill
and the study bill basically we brought
in uh you know people to testify to with
regards to you know let's let's build it
over the uh
the jetty
and there were a lot there was a lot of
discussion a lot of people that were
local there they came in to to look at
that and uh they said well you know we
got we got a headache with that
and the headache is is that the army
corps of engineers basically uh you know
they would have issues with us building
a pier over that and of course the you
know it's there for a specific reason
so some people offered up
a compromise that's something we do in
the senate we compromise and so
uh somebody suggested well how about if
we just moved it instead of over the
the jetty
how about if we just put it up by boar's
head and there's a 10-year highway plan
out there that that it would coincide
with that and we
we could uh you know look look at the
the feasibility of of having it there
and that way
people could drive up
park get in their wheelchair
and scroll out onto the jetty
not the jetty the pier and and and maybe
cast an angle or those that are are
disabled that can get out there and
enjoy the ocean like the rest of us can
that that are able-bodied
so uh we came up with an amendment
uh and uh so and in the amendment the
basically is what this should be before
you uh the amendment by replacing all
after acting the clause with the
following
hampton beach peer feasibility study
the hampton beach area commission shall
study the feasibility and impact since
constructing a peer directly
south of borah's head in the town of
hampton
the commission shall report its finding
and any recommendations for proposed
legislation to the speaker of the house
and representatives the president of the
senate and the house clerk and the
senate clerk and the governor and in the
state library on before november first
appropriations
uh the sum of 150 000 for the fiscal
year ending june 30 uh 2023 is hereby
appropriated to hampton beach area
commission for the feasibility study
related
uh to building a pier in the town of
hampton
the governor is authorized to draw a
warrant for said some amount
in the treasury not otherwise
appropriate and the effective date is 60
days after its passage the whole concept
here is that you know we have the
penguin plunge
we have uh
the disability community that that could
benefit from this and by the way you
know there would also be a tourist draw
if we can at least pass this stage of of
the bill and you know at least look at
the feasibility of you know is this is
this appropriate
can we do it
what about the weather and i keep
reminding people
there's piers in florida there's peers
at myrtle beach if you've been to myrtle
beach there's piers that
in new jersey
so piers are possible and they can be
made in such a way that
they're weather resistant or they can
tolerate the weather but the whole
reason for this is so that the
disability community
can enjoy what we enjoy
and uh so i
i'm looking at all your smiling faces
i'm hoping that you would join me and
pass this
so
thank you mr chair i'll take any
questions if you have any ah thank you
senator questions of the senator
what would cost 150 000 to study like
what would that money be used for uh
again it would be an engineering
feasibility study and uh it it was the
number was derived on the potential cost
of the actual pier so it's about 10
percent uh
earmarked it's it's it's not a
scientific number but it's
that's what uh my understanding is is
when i look at the handout
when i look at the bill line two it says
uh appear directly south of boer's head
but on the next page in the methodology
it says uh directly north of borah's
head
i would think that the people of hampton
that really matters is north or south of
boris head
which would you prefer
i let the study tell us
yeah it's uh i believe it is the south
part it's it's it's the northern part of
the beach but south of boer's head if i
understand correctly but i have some
professionals from me that can actually
answer uh
uh
in more detail but i think that's that
that's the
i'm sure it'll get worked out in the
details yeah thank you thank you for the
question
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question senator could you
give us your vision of this pier
uh the size of it is it going to have
businesses on it is it going to have a
bait store on it or is it just going to
be a small walkway pier
do you envision it being 200 feet long
and can you just give us an idea of what
your vision of the pier is well my
personal vision was uh probably the
length of
say the
the jetty that was my personal vision
but i know that the local community will
have more of a say on on the length of
it
and the use of it but uh keeping in mind
that my primary function here is for
people to go out on the pier
uh
not just an ad not not just a
straightforward but something where
people can actually go out on a pier and
fish
or
go out and enjoy the breeze in
whatever you want to do on the pier
in in nashua we have um mine falls we're
all familiar with mine falls and of
course
there's a walkway down mine falls
and
you got these little cutouts in the
walkway
and there's this drop-off
and then there's a bunch of weeds
okay so you can go up there and you can
pretend you're going to fish but the
rail's so high
that you know people can't uh they
really can't you can go out there and
you can be stuck in a little cove so i
want it to be handicapped if you will
friendly
but uh i would like the locals to
actually talk about the the the scope
and size of it but it's specifically so
that people of all walks of life can get
out there enjoy the ocean fish off it i
don't know if there's a pavilion at the
end of it but i do also know that there
was a discussion
for rescue search and rescue i don't
know if you know that in at the jetty a
lot of people get hurt every year
there's a there's a local cost for
people getting hurt
uh if you've ever watched how they had
to to pull up a boat and get the people
out there to rescue these people that
have fallen in the in the jetty at the
end of the pier maybe maybe have a a
certain area where you can have the the
sea doo's if you will to so you don't
have to
uh traverse the the breakers a place for
search and rescue to be able to be
parked there as well so it gives them an
advantage over the tidal waves or
whatever
but um
uh i i think that the the local uh
people there should have more of a say
as to because they have to live with it
and uh and uh so but i i just that's my
vision is for people to be able to go
out there and enjoy a quality uh
um
i don't know if there's such a word but
there's good fishing and there's bad
fishing and
i want them to be able to enjoy it in in
such a way that they can take advantage
of it whereas we can
so i don't know if that answers your
question but uh
thank you
representative evil
hi um senator abard so
usually what happens is that you would
have a study committee or a commission
that would investigate a certain idea
and depending on the recommendations
then you might proceed with a
feasibility study in the appropriation
of money
rather than wrapping the whole thing at
once so i just wanted i wondered if you
could explain the
the process a little bit because it's
conceivable the commission might come
back after a preliminary study and and
decide that it's not a good idea and
then the money would already have been
appropriated i really appreciate the
question but this is a result of a study
committee that we had oh okay yeah and
and uh we we kind of uh went through all
that and this is the result of that
study committee
uh so we you know now we're at the the
feasibility part and of course i i
really think that the local people from
hampton would and the commission there
would have a uh a better grasp as as far
as the design uh rather than uh the
state you know coming in saying hey we
want up here and so there'll be a
relationship between the state and the
local community uh with regards to it
because it'll be a state park
but i believe that there'll be a
relationship with the local community as
far as it's upkeep and whatnot but i can
let the senator stiles which i believe
is here former senator styles
to talk a little bit about that if
that's okay and uh and end
the process
thank you further
questions
cnn thanks very much
thank you so if i may i'm going to go
back over there and fight for your bills
that's what senator french would usually
say so i'm going to go over there and
try to fight for your bills thank you
committee and thank you mr chair
uh
next is another sponsor
thank you very much for the record my
name is senator tom sherman district 24
which is hampton and hampton beach
and i'm don't have a whole lot more to
add to what senator avart
said i just
this has been a really great process
through the committee
which i served on with senator evart as
chair
lots of input lots of imagination and
really changing the idea of of this
walkway over a jetty to something that
is
really if you go up and down the east
coast or up and down the west coast some
of the highlights of those visits are
these piers jutting out into the water
and allowing disabled access
and one of the areas
that would be really important to that
that beach is
allowing safety access out beyond the
breakers
my son's a huge surfer and
the idea of being able to get beyond the
breakers to rescue somebody who's either
had been a victim of undertow or
otherwise without having to go through
them
is is a big benefit to this but
it's really an exciting project it's uh
it could be a huge draw
and just to answer representative
evil's
concerns
we have started engaging
many different
stakeholders including
just so you know there's
right now department of transportation
is looking at ocean boulevard and so the
commissioner is aware of this and
is thinking how could this be
incorporated into some of the new work
that's going to be done in the new
design of ocean boulevard as it goes
through that area so
hugely exciting
something the community is rallying
around and
and i think it's also strikes
a real
balance between what's doable
sustainable
and also what's great for our disabled
population as well as for safety issues
regarding that area of the seacoast so
i'm happy to take any questions
questions for the senator
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
mr john
nahan do i say that right
close enough who
supported the bill from the hampton area
chamber of commerce
welcome to the committee thank you mr
chairman and members of the committee
um
my name is john nyan president of the
hampton area chamber of commerce
i represent five communities
around the seacoast
where we have
over 500
members of the chamber of commerce
many of which are
located along the seacoast
from rye all the way down to seabrook
i'd like to start and i'll keep my
comments brief
because i know you have a lot of work to
do but i'd like to start with showing
pictures i believe pictures sometimes
says a lot more than words and i believe
representative newton you had asked
about the vision
so i have three pictures here that i'd
like just to share with the community if
it's all right with you mr chairman
the first one is the jetty itself
and what it looks like and what it could
look like after
a storm
the second is a picture of exactly where
we are proposing uh the pier to be
considered and then the third and most
importantly is what the pair would look
like as our vision so if i may i'll pass
this around while i'm talking
and for the members of the committee as
long as they end up with the clerk we're
good okay
okay
back in october um when this was in fact
a study committee
i attended the
senator's
meeting up here in concord and
we had talked because i had spoken to a
number of business
owners along the beach and to talk about
what they thought uh regarding the
present jetty and whether or not it
would be appropriate to put a pier
and the consensus was no it was too
dangerous
with the the water coming in
storms
it would just not be a a good place to
put a
built up pier because it would be
probably in need of repair within the
first couple of years
so we had as a local community made a
suggestion for them to consider putting
a pier on hampton beach but not at the
jetty but right south
of boy's head not north but south of
boy's head
and the picture as you will see as you
will get it you will see exactly where
i reference
so i was happy uh when the
committee decided that they would take
our recommendation
and and move the the site of the pier
from a business perspective um i have
been associated with a number of
projects uh i was formerly prior to
senator stiles i was the chairman of the
hampton beach area commission for 10
years
was very much involved with the senator
and others with regard to the
redevelopment of hampton beach state
park
and one of the things that we
proposed
here in concord when we got that capital
funding was a return on investment
and so from that point on we've always
looked at how do we create
public-private partnerships the business
community along with state parks how can
we continue to improve
the beach area
but do it in a way where we're also
improving the revenue coming into the
state
for those of you that might have
followed
the redevelopment
the state gave us 14.5 million dollars
to redevelop hampton beach state park
back in 2010 2011.
that money
i believe has created not only more
money into the state revenue part but in
terms of across the street over 180
million dollars
has been invested in either new
development or redevelopment on hampton
beach today that's a lot of money
so when we look at this pier we look at
it as an added
reason why you should come to hampton
beach
to enjoy
the beach
we have now hosted for our second year
in a row a senior day
at the beach we take seniors from
nursing homes assisted livings senior
clubs and we treat them to a day at the
beach
and i was just thinking the other day
wouldn't it be so nice
to have as part of that program for the
seniors to be able to come and walk to
the pier and actually walk out into the
ocean wouldn't that be a nice experience
for all of them
so
what i'm saying um gentlemen and ladies
that
i think it's really important that we
move forward with this study
there's a lot of questions that still
cannot be answered because of it being
still in a feasibility comp status and i
think part of the reason why
we want to to move forward is to see
if in fact
there is feasibility in doing this i
know the business community is in full
support of this concept
we work very well with state parks on a
number of uh initiatives and so we would
be working with state parks and any
other organizations so i would ask uh
this committee to uh vote in favor of
moving this forward and i'd be more than
happy to answer any questions thank you
um thank you
questions
i do have one
bill
representative boyd excuse me
that's okay thank you mr chairman
thank you for your testimony mr narhan
and thank you for the pictures i
appreciate that so the proposed pier is
going to be south of boar's head
that is correct okay
um
have you begun any preliminary dialogue
with the border selectmen in hampton and
the residents and the neighbors
regarding just the the conceptual idea
of putting the pier at that location
yes i have had we've had a number of
business discussions with a number of
business
businesses
i work well with an organization called
the hampton beach village district which
is a sub category subdivision of the
town of hampton
they're in favor of this
i have had direct conversations with
the town manager and uh members of the
board of selectmen
okay thank you mr chairman yeah well
um
the one question that i have looking at
this
there is a report date of november 1st
the act won't take effect until 60 days
after passage which puts it into june or
july
will that be sufficient time to do this
kind of a study
even if we were to pass it and give you
all the money
that's a great question mr chairman
and one of the things that i was very
happy
to see as an amendment to this bill
was the transfer
of the responsibility of overseeing this
to the hampton beach area commission
which senator stiles
is the chair
and whether or not you're a democrat
republican um
um personal friends with the senator and
i have been for many years and if
there's anybody
that can make this happen down at the
hampton beach area it would be senator
stiles
any further questions
and before we get to the agencies i'll
call on um
former senator stiles
whose card is making its way up here
um
to public works once again
well thank you very much and for the
record i am nancy stiles
and currently chair of the hampton beach
area commission which is an advisory
committee to both the state and the town
to improve the economic development at
hampton beach that's what
one of our tasks is
volunteered
this um this whole project um
will be a huge addition to the beach as
far as those with walking disabled many
of you some of you may know that when i
was served in the house i was adamant
that we look at our walking disabled
community that they deserved as many
rights as we have
and when senator avad mentioned to me
that he wanted to put up a pier that
would be accessible for walking disabled
and i want to refer to the time schedule
that
chairman just spoke to of november 1st
that's when the report would be due
i know that it'll go through this
committee and i'm hoping it can move as
quickly as possible with deliberation as
you go through and then it'll probably
have to go to finance is that correct
finance and then i'll go to the floor
and then i'll have to get signed and uh
governor will have to okay it
so you're right it'll probably be june
at best
before it would get all the way through
the process
i think that is one of the reasons why
they put that amount of money in in the
senate knowing that it is going to take
a heavy hammer
to get that job done
and any of you that have worked with me
in the past know that i am about
deadlines
and the deadline is november 1st
and as if i am put in charge
do you have any questions you'd like to
ask me i mean the the commission that i
sit on in case some of you may not know
is made up of two members of uh the town
two members of the village district at
the beach
park state parks
and d.o.t
the chamber of commerce
the
members of the business community
rockingham
planning and an ad hoc person
so there's nine of us on the commission
and
they are dedicated to working together
so if you have questions for me about
the pier um one of the things in the
feasibility study one of the things that
i think that they will find out is is
south of
buzz head the best place to put it
that's one of the things i think they
will discover in the feasibility so if
you have a question about whether it's
north or south i think you'll get that
answer
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
has anybody considered the feasibility
of the parking because you this pier is
being pushed as handicapped accessible
and how much more handicapped accessible
parking
will you need and is it feasible
to have as much
handicap parking as you will need for
the draw that it's going to be with all
these handicapped people
going to use the pier because right now
i go to hampton quite a bit and it's
wonderful it's great which you guys have
done
to date but the parking is always a
problem
a big problem so i'd like to hear if you
discuss that or you'll be talking about
that with your feasibility study well we
just recently
finished the
updating of the master plan for tr
transportation we're in the process now
of doing it for the environmental
component and that parking area was part
of the study for the
part of our study for the uh
transportation component of our master
plan and yes there would be room for to
do that because many of you may know
that at hampton beach if you are walking
disabled you can park anywhere
for nothing
so there's nothing that's scheduled for
anybody in particular but there would
have to be a special area pulled off and
so we would be in a communication with
the engineering group that is is doing
route 1a
there's an engineering group that is
studying the layout of route 1a so we if
this goes through
we would be in communication with that
engineering group to make sure that that
is accounted for so that the walking
disabled would have a place to park
thank you
further questions
representative edgar
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
it seems that uh some of the urgency
that you've been expressing uh has to do
with the fact that ocean boulevard is in
the design
process right now is that correct that's
correct okay so it does
lend some urgency to it
further questions
uh yes please
besides besides comments excuse me sir
um
the uh
the other one is is it um you had
mentioned your commitment uh
and you still feel strongly that uh if
you if this is passed then you get the
money in your hands by around the
earliest time i believe by this would be
june 31st that you'll be able to
complete this work
by november 1st i can work as quickly as
you do so yes
well maybe a little quicker
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you for saying them thank you i
would remind committee members if there
is no eating or drinking within the
committee room while we're having
hearings
from uh new hampshire des uh mr renny
pelletier
in
support of the bill
which is not what the letter i got from
your boss this morning said
that's why that's actually why i'm here
i don't think we really
have a part in this bill but what
by design that i had sent over to you
was so it provided some sort of a
history of where we were
as you can see on 347 we did the fiscal
note and pretty much said that we didn't
have the in-house expertise
so
my feeling was when we sent that letter
that it would more serve as a little
history
we were fortunate enough to be asked to
participate in the study committee
as you can see in the letter if you had
a chance to read that we had some
suggestions talking with senator stiles
and other members of the committee
it was really refreshing to see the
approach that senator avad took for an
amendment so
as you know we permit all structures
that are built on the seacoast
and we feel that historically the port
authority does a lot of this work they
do a lot of feasibility studies to in
in in fact determine the safety the
location the depth the tide all that
stuff so the approach i think is uh the
norm
and uh
i'm glad to see that the bill was
amended and
other than that
ah thank you mr pelletier actually i
read of this he just sent the same
letter he said to the senate
no no i put a few edits in there
and a question for mr pelletier from
anyone
representative boyd
thank you mr chairman
and before i ask my question i sincerely
apologize for my
indiscretion
mr pelletier
what is the
north west and southerly boundaries of
hampton beach state park
that's a very good question we we have
somebody from the director of parks and
recreation will be next i'll obey my
any further questions of des on this
bill
now
mr philip bryce director of division of
parks and recreation
um in support of the bill and he does
have written testimony
red is on huh okay so uh
thank you mr chairman uh members of the
committee my name is philip bryce
director of the department of uh the
division of uh
parks and recreation in the department
of natural and cultural resources
uh i did provide a written testimony i
might add another couple of comments to
that um
so
um we we do appreciate the support of
the senate and the changes they made to
the bill
to enable the hampton beach area
commission which we sit on to lead the
study
that commission assists the town and the
state
in the planning around hampton beach
uh
we do know that there's a lot of
interest in that type of experience
because of the people that uh you
utilize the pier
i mean the um not the peer the jetty
and um while we have our lifeguards on
in the summer and end up having to do
rescues out there
uh in the winter time we don't and that
falls on the town um or uh or other
resources to help people out there
so we know that there's demand for this
this would provide an alternative for
folks to get out over the water
we assume that a consult would be hired
to conduct the studies
and as a point of reference and as
mentioned before
design costs are generally 10 of the
construction costs with that with that
in mind of course the senate amended uh
the amount
the division very much supports
improvements across the
park system improve accessibility to the
outdoors one of our latest projects is
the fishing platform and trail up in
franconia notch state park at the old
man memorial if you haven't had a chance
to go up there of course it's a gorgeous
spot
um and uh um
memorial itself is is is pretty uh neat
spot
in addition uh the pier would provide an
additional attraction that could
increase off season uh visitation that
has been one of our efforts
we we actually now operate our restrooms
year round we plow the sidewalks we plow
parking lots that that
that used to not happen
and um if you're out there particularly
in the even in the late fall or
particularly in the early spring there's
a lot of people that are out
using
using the beach
and the facilities that we provide there
and
however as mentioned
earlier an essential part of the
feasibility impact study would be to
understanding the impact on and degree
of support from the community local law
enforcement emergency services and of
course the abutters to the pier
whoever would be responsible for
managing the pier would likely also want
to to understand any operating costs
including
maintenance and repair
and the lifespan of the pier
to consider future replacement and
revenue support in revenue to
support those costs this is particularly
important given of course the impact
that winter storms uh have on structures
along the seacoast however there are
peers
as you all know up and down the entire
eastern seaboard so there's plenty of
examples thank you very much for the
opportunity to provide testimony i'm
glad to answer any questions
questions
from members of the committee
representative boyd
thank you mr chairman
now i'll ask my question
um mr price what is the
geographic boundaries for hampton beach
state park
the best response would be for me to
look to get a map of that for you uh the
beach itself is the
um would be the sand um
uh
as you as you go towards the south side
of
um boar's head
um
at that end and down at the uh
south end of course it would be along
the edge of the rv park there out to the
pier
so um and then you have north beach it's
right basically at the end of the sea
wall
and then runs all the way up and
intersects with the town uh with the
town park but i could provide a map if
we um if you if if you would like like
to see one please and one more follow-up
mr chairman thank you
mr bryson your testimony you talked
about the management of the peer did i i
don't mean to be put words in your mouth
but i inferred from it that that would
be something that would not be managed
by the state but would be contracted out
is that of is that a fair assumption
well
i
we didn't want to speculate or assume
that it was going to be parks that
manage it if it's for fishing it could
be fish and game it could be the um you
know the uh um
another authority that that does
that you know does that work
um so we just we just left that
we didn't want to make the assumption
that it was going to be parks that was
actually managing the pier
well we might be managing while we would
continue to obviously manage the
associated resources such as the parking
lots and the restrooms that would
support that
i'll defer mr chamberfield
thank you
any further questions
we have do we have
handicapped accessible
access to the beaches currently
and
i know we have handicapped accessible
wheelchairs
i'm just wondering if there's a cost for
those and
if you could explain how
people would get onto the beach
yeah for people that that can't handle
the walking across the sand
we have two things one is we we
we've actually changed to use a new
technology around some mats um
and gotten rid of the wooden
um the wooden platforms that go out onto
the beach to let people get out onto the
sand
so that is one thing because it the sand
can be a little difficult if you have uh
any and it's it's difficult to move a um
uh
can be difficult to move across the sand
so this makes it easier for people to
walk with a you know if they're they're
have assistance the primary way though
that people uh get out on the beach is
with the the beach wheelchairs with the
big wheels
uh and that's how they and that's how
they access the um you know get out
further into the sand our lifeguards
operate that program i'm not sure how
many chairs we have but we continue to
try to continue to
to get more um and make it more variable
uh
available i can tell you
uh it's it they get a lot of use and i
can i can give you those numbers but i
don't have them off the top of my head
just to follow this to speak um if we
could keep the questions
to the feasibility study on whether or
not we are going to do it and not other
aspects of the
representative evil
i think i'm in a bit of a gray zone so
i'm going to go ahead and ask the
question
i mean it
the the the state is being asked to fund
the feasibility study and then i did
also notice the information here that
you weren't clear on who would be
managing the peer
is it ultimately
the concept that the cost of the peer if
it proved feasible would be a
state park
capital budget sort of an item or is
that
of course there's multiple sources of
funding that are around right now um
and
um the if i could just jump back it is
my assumption it would be a state agency
that would run it because the state's
providing the it's just not sure which
entity would be the one to do that
uh the source of funding i that's and
that is
up to
um you know the legislature and the
i mean we're just following
representative peterson go ahead it's
all right no i was just going to i'm
sorry mr chair no no i already called on
thank you mr chair
my question is
to your knowledge does the state of
maine have any peers
similar to the design being proposed
here
someone else here might know that the
answer to that question we have not
explored this at all ourselves any
further um really
uh obviously at that point at which um a
decision is made we would move forward i
i would think that maine would have have
some peers i know there's peers to the
south
in massachusetts that i think is
operated by their fishing game
department for uh for fishing maine we
did not um we haven't asked about
follow-up does it deal with the
feasibility study
uh
never mind
representative evil back
okay
representative newman
yes and i'm going to direct this um to
the feasibility study thank you
um
not knowing it
okay if if you don't know that there are
any
similar peers in maine
but there are some in massachusetts
i just want to confirm that the
feasibility study in all likelihood
would include
winter weather conditions and peer
upkeep maintenance and
accessibility issues
thank you
yes thank you very good question and i i
addressed that and completely supported
that in my testimony which um the folks
representative faulkner
and i'm pretty sure this is related to
the visibility study
will you be able to look at
other ways of funding ongoing
maintenance and i'm particularly
thinking about whether
it's feasible to charge concessionaires
bait sales but whatever
for use of the property whether the some
restrictions that might limit the
ability to
for additional sources of ongoing
maintenance income
yes a good question again i i'm hoping
that in the feasibility study that the
ongoing maintenance costs are identified
and and then there's alternative sources
of funding it could be that the
community comes forward and supports
those maintenance costs i've heard that
idea thrown out as opposed to requiring
the park system or the state to support
it
representative thompson
um
you're the second person who referred to
the
150 000 as
10 of the cost
is am i assuming that the cost is
a million and a half dollars to build
this beer because
pretty much
not sure you can do it for that
um representative thompson always a good
question uh we knew that the amount they
put in the original mill which i think
was 25 000 was not nearly sufficient
so um
it's it's a very good question uh you
know it
it was to give a sense of of the scale
that at least it's going to cost a
million and a half so you need 150 000
to do this study but a very good
question we don't know the cost you know
the the costs of everything have gone up
as you know substantially so we'll
we'd have to
again they'll have to identify that and
the size and scale of the peer may be
dictated by the cost so
thank you very much chairman
further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
i have no further pink cards is anybody
who has not spoken wish to
testify about
senate bill 346 is anybody who's
testified once we should speak a second
time see none i will close the public
hearing on senate bill 346.
this is an early bill it has to be
so i would like to open the executive
session on senate bill 346.
um if the committee is not willing to do
that we'll be back here probably next
tuesday
i'm just being honest
um
let's do a little bit of general
discussion at before we take a motion
representative edgar um
because i know what your emotion will
anybody have any generalized comments
about
whether or not we should accept this
bill
representative thompson i do
um
i probably have
as much experience with hampton beach as
i think that
to try and put a appear at boar's head
south of boar's head
um i'm sure that
the director as well as senator styles
can
can comment on when there's a high tide
or an exceptional high tide
where does the water come over the sea
wall at hampton beach
right where you propose to put the pier
and
that area i believe
we senator styles you'd call the rocky
part of the beach if you could not
address people in the audience we are
having a discussion among members of the
committee i would appreciate it because
they cannot respond at this point
the the public hearing is closed
so if you have comments address them to
the members of the committee please okay
my feeling is that uh
that area is not
um
what i would call a constructable area
on the sea coast
particularly on hampton beach just
because of the way the tides run run
as we all know
you call it climate change you can call
it whatever you want
it's having effect on our beaches and
our seacoast i construct sea walls on
the seacoast
as a matter of
course and
i've worked for recently has asked to
raised it's just
i i guess i would have to see
how high this pier is supposed to be
um is it going to be above clear tide
which is
an exceptional high tide if it isn't
there's an opportunity for people to be
swept off
the pier
at low tide
the area they're talking about is
exceptionally
shallow
and if someone were to jump off it
thinking they had 20 feet of water
underneath them i think they'd have a
rude awakening when their feet hit the
bottom
um i just i
am not in favor of this at all
representative klasik
thank you
um
well i don't think that we're arguing
about whether we're going to build
a peer or not that's not what the bill
is the bill is whether there should be a
feasibility study where they will
thank you you took
something representative boyd you've had
your hand up for a while sorry
that's okay mr chairman thank you i
amplify
representative lasik's comments that
we're gonna talk about the feasibility
not about the location what i
what i can say is that
respecting representative thompson's
knowledge of the area and my knowledge
of
having
i'm an active runner and i love running
up and down to the north beach and back
that that's i personally feel that's a
tough location but that's going to be
the community's decision to decide so
that's one particular point number two
to go to representative peterson's point
the only three peers that i know of a
castle island rockport and in the old
port of portland on the on the on the
north side by where the uh where the
railroad used to be located those are
the only three that come to mind off the
top of my head so i think
looking and exploring that as a
potential
destination for our state i think
would be
is particularly noteworthy because it's
it's to me those things are really kind
of kind of unique and then the the last
point that i would make is that
within the context of this feasibility
study i would hope because i i really
feel it's a stallion point what are the
true boundaries of the hampton beach
state park because we certainly don't
want to be looking at a site and not
have it be a part of the state park
because then technically it's going to
be somebody else's responsibility to
consent so
those are the points i wanted to make my
colleagues aware of mr chairman thank
you
thank you uh representative abbott
yes um
in regards to the feasibility study
i just don't think
the first of november
is a
a good day to
have this done and i question how
thorough a study could be
done
if if this doesn't pass until june
and uh
yes thank you mr chairman i have to
concur with representative abbott
i
either what comes to my mind with the
deadline is haste makes waste and i
think there's a whole lot of stuff to
consider
with the weather
with the area and i just don't see
how it could be done in such short order
and be
thorough and complete
to move forward i do think that a study
should be done and and i would suggest
maybe if somebody could get the local
businesses to pony up 50 or 75 grand and
they could get started on it on their
own they would have a good jump start on
it
and just make sure
the eyes are dotted and the t's are
crossed
when it comes to the legislature for
money
but i do think that needs to be a study
done i just don't see how it can be done
by november 1st
thank you um and to propose an amendment
just so everybody knows and everybody in
this room should know it
our term ends the first tuesday
after the first what first wednesday
after the first tuesday
in december so any reports that were due
would have to be done before then um
because this term will be finished
um
so even
trying to amend this to a later date in
the spring or something would would not
be
useful i served on one committee at one
point
and it had a report date in the
following like january february and the
speaker
newly elected speaker at the time just
went nope you're done it's all finished
we've never even made a report
it it
is tough to do
um
each one of us will have to make up our
mind whether or not
um doing this kind of a study
um quickly um
is worth it for the long term of the
state
um that being said
um
representative boyd
thank you mr chairman a question to you
can the can the price tag be amended at
this time
if you want to go over to legislative
services and get a
we will all wait for you
it's the only way it can be done
or
if the committee so chooses
i can schedule a meeting next tuesday i
don't want to come next tuesday if the
committee is willing to indulge me for a
two hours oh boy i don't keep okay at
least an hour at least an hour okay
um
however i will remind everybody that
this is going to finance from here
and the amount
can be amended at that point
um
so i
we can
whoever writes the committee report can
can make a recommendation that they need
to look at
the uh
the dollar amount or or a minority
report if it comes down to that um
but
just so everybody knows we
this goes into the calendar that is
published a week from thursday
one way or the other it goes into that
calendar we will vote on it on the 21st
of april
it then goes to finance assuming that it
passes the floor
or if it doesn't then it's dead um
and then they have to work it in and
they have until the first week or so in
may to to finish it but
they can do anything they want with the
dollar amount um
so i i would suggest that
whatever we do
that if
there is concern about the absolute
dollar amount that we take those
concerns to finance
when the bill is heard
i will get be notified
obviously when the bill is going to be
heard because it came through this
committee
and can make sure everybody knows
but you can also reach out to members to
finance and raise a question about the
dollar amount
and then it would be up to them to
question
whoever comes to testify in support of
the bill or whether that dollar amount
is could be lowered because i'm sure
nobody's recommending that we raise it
somebody
does that answer your question
representative boyd yeah i just
i know i know representative newton
makes a salient point which is why i
asked yeah it is
um but we'll see what the committee does
i will defer to the member from hampton
to make a motion
uh i move uh
you know the bill uh
sb
346 uh auto pass and i like to speak to
the motion
representative edgar has moved out to
pass on senate bill 346 fna
um
as amended by the senate um
representative eaton uh seconds that
uh representative edgar is recognized to
speak to his motion
uh thank you mr chair
i first like to say that uh
it does seem and it's i questioned it
myself the
short time period by the time that
hopefully this will be approved and get
through the process and when it has to
be handed in
i'm i also feel quite confident that
that doesn't mean that nothing's going
to be done in the meantime or lined up
and i have all confidence
that uh
that there will be preliminary type
arrangements made in that the report
would be uh
in on time on november 1st
i think it would be a
really good uh ad addition to the
seacoast
and i i hope uh
it's agreed that we should get this done
and also as it's tied into the planning
uh that's going on now for ocean
boulevard would be uh would be a real
big help
representative samara
yes
representative philadelphia no
representative newton no
representative blasic
yes
representative thompson
no
representative boyd
representative edgar aye
representative ebel aye
representative jack yes
representative abbott
no
representative newman
yes
representative eaton yes
representative quarry
no
mr chair the the vote is 14-6 in favor
with a vote of 14-6 the
motion about to pass
is approved
will there be
a minority report from
anybody
seeing none
and obviously because it is an
appropriation it will be on the regular
calendar anyways
um
that is it
for all of the bills that we have i
appreciate everybody
being here
um
representative edgar do you have your
report written
i will
i will chairman thank you
um
anything else i think i gave i sent out
to everybody the
um
when the house will be meeting
um so
it is
important that we make the meetings
and we will be done by
memorial day as the calendar and our
house rules specify so
um
see no further business to come before
us
we stand adjourned to the call of the
chair
you